I'm hopeful vice with Bobby kalila alsa
okay this question comes from Ray Ray
hey guys
I've been homeless I already know hey
guys I've been homeless in Miami for
about five months now I am only 26 and I
have no idea what to do with my life I
know I want to write and illustrate
graphic novels but doing what I why
living on the streets has proved nearly
impossible I don't how many crazy
addictions or drug issues I'll do i do
love marijuana
I met the lowest I've ever been but I
don't have kids or responsibilities and
even with a little bit of money I do
have I make as a dishwasher I can drop
it all and move somewhere I'll move
someplace else I've been thinking of
heading west to LA since I've never been
but would I be trading one place of
problems for another what do you guys
think
don't be homeless well I mean he doesn't
have a choice sometime where you don't
know his circumstances it's that human
suffering that makes great art should
how long how much longer should he stay
homeless and should he suffer in LA or
Miami that's the question I know but I
think this is I am me you stay in Miami
it's good row here is rough way over LA
for a homeless person I Lorna has like
people that's crazy
if you were a homeless person we're with
you I would think about this all [ __ ]
time okay really all the time I'm like
at all at all times I'm prepared to get
homeless so you're like the highest tax
bracket so I okay so I have I have my
savings account obviously and then I
have like another savings account with a
lot less money but don't you hate
talking about money I hate talking about
money but I just have to say this so if
I ever am down to just that savings
account I'm gonna fly an RV like a
Winnebago gonna be my home I'll buy a
used shitty one you know yeah so and
then um I don't know obviously someplace
warm it's always changing I thought
Hawaii would be the perfect
to be homeless yeah because I mean a lot
of you know those beach people are kind
of like living that kind of lifestyle
anyway nothing they're homeless Chris
Pratt did it it's a lot I yeah like I
think it's just a more relaxed you know
Tamiya suki was I'm Sam kinnison's
girlfriend she's Asian
she's comedian she was on a sitcom I
forgot what I was called but she went
crazy and she went to Hawaii she lived
in the jungle and she built the house in
the jungle no I know but I'm just saying
though like if you were gonna do that
that's what you were doing
who does parrots and waterfalls yeah I
think the most important factor in
homelessness is weather yeah Oh totally
like homeless people in New York not
that you know I mean I understand like
they're mentally unhealthy and blah blah
blah yeah but I mean it's the worst
[ __ ] place Chicago but they're also
yeah would just be game over for me just
kill me but also you know if there was a
plague to ever hit California or you
know a big city like New York only the
homeless would survive those people's
immune systems are so strong they're so
primed for different weather pattern
changes they're just they're so exposed
to the elements on a daily basis they
don't leave cushy lives so they're the
only ones there like they're like the
cockroaches of humanity they'll never
die true what the walk they already have
all the survival yeah they know how to
survive yeah on so little so but so
what's the answer for this guy what was
the question I'm here LA I mean I think
stay in Miami but don't feel bad about
the hardships you're going through
because that's gonna make you strong and
that's gonna you know motivate you to
create the masterpiece that's gonna get
you out of it and definitely stop
listening to our podcast cuz we do our
pies but it's free well then sell your
iPhone
no no but I've one thing in the world
won't be enough nobody is that really is
that true with what they get the world I
I think so I mean aside from food and
water that's a survival gadget onus for
survival you you can call for rides you
can call clinics you can go out yeah
Google Maps you can
Oh cash yeah you know I think pick up
free t-shirts along the way when I was
on MADtv I had homeless people go and
man loved you on that TV it's like well
you know like mole people oh yeah under
the subways in New York oh yeah yeah
like they had TVs and stuff yeah and
there's a over here the tunnels in Echo
Park led to an under underworld a city
Wow we went down into the tunnels you
broke down they put concrete over it now
but they're in the 90s when I first
moved here me my friend Laban and my
brother and a bunch of us went we took
flashlights and survival kits and we try
to go down as far as we could I'm
telling you right it gets pitch black
and it gets [ __ ] scary dude you saw a
lot of people down there no you can't
you don't even get that far you go about
500 feet and then you're like I need to
get out of here yeah cuz you start
hearing things you know I mean I think
that we should do a challenge I've
always wanted to do a show where we all
like put ourselves in like uncomfortable
situations and the three of us or the
four of us we should live like ask see
who lasts longest living homeless for
like for like five days and see who
actually thrives the best I'll tell you
something I would hate that but I'd win
kind of cocky because I literally suck
dick for money oh that's true already oh
I don't think you would suck any dick
though yeah you know we're not allowed
to that's the rule you can't you can't
no she's not sucking you're sucking you
know mean like tested you know nice dick
yeah for money
nice money but I mean come on I'm
halfway there no the dicks that are out
there yeah yeah I don't think you would
so if we were to borrow jump for me to
to suck some strange untested [ __ ] a
dirty [ __ ] is much smaller than the jump
you'd have to make yeah no he's
[Music]